so let's say that we've got a pool of
water and i drop a rock into the middle
of that pool of water i drop a rock in
the middle of that pool of water and a
little while later a ripple has a little
wave a ripple has formed that is moving
radially outward from where i dropped
the rocks let me see how well i can draw
that so it's moving radially outward so
that is the ripple that is formed from
me dropping the rock into the water
so it's a circle centered at where the
rock initially hit the water and let's
say right at this moment the radius of
this circle
the radius of the circle is equal to
three centimeters
is equal to three centimeters and we
also know
we also know that the radius is
increasing at a rate of one
centimeter per second so radius
radius growing
growing
at
rate
of one
centimeter per second so given this
right now our circle our ripple circle
has a radius of three centimeters and we
know that the radius is growing at one
centimeter per second given that at what
rate is the area growing
at
what
rate
is area of circle
area
of circle
circle
growing
interesting
so let's think about what we know and
then what we don't know what we're
trying to figure out
so if we call this radius r we we know
that right now r
is equal to three centimeters
we also know the rate at which the
radius with the rate at which r is
changing with respect to time we also
know this information right over here dr
dt the rate at which the radius is
changing with respect to time is one
centimeter per second
one
centimeter per second now what do we
need to figure out
well they said what rate is the area of
the circle growing so we need to figure
out what rate is the area of the circle
where a is the area of the circle at
what rate is this growing
this is what we need to figure out
so what might be useful here is if we
can come up with a relationship between
the area of the circle and the radius of
the circle and maybe take the derivative
with respect to time and we'll have to
use a little bit of the chain rule to do
that so what is the relationship at any
given point in time between the area of
the circle and the radius of the circle
well this is this is
elementary geometry the area of a circle
is going to be equal to pi times the
radius of the circle
the radius of the circle squared
now what we want to do is figure out the
rate at which the area is changing with
respect to time so why don't we take the
derivative of both sides of this with
respect to time and let me give myself a
little more real estate actually let me
just rewrite what i just had
so pi
pi
r squared
area is equal to pi r squared i'm going
to take the derivative of both sides of
this with respect to time
so the derivative with respect to time
i'm not taking the derivative with
respect to r i'm taking the derivative
with respect to time
so on the left hand side right over here
i'm going to have the derivative of our
area
actually let me just write it in that
green color i'm going to have
i'm going to have whoops
i'm going to have
the derivative of our area with respect
to time on the left hand side and on the
right hand side what do i have
well if i'm taking the derivative of a
constant times something i can take the
constant out so let me just do that pi
times the derivative with respect to
time the derivative with respect to time
of r squared and i make it a little bit
clearer what i'm about to do why i'm
using the chain rule we're assuming that
r is a function of time if r wasn't a
function of time then area wouldn't be a
function of time so let me write instead
of just writing r let me make it
explicit that it is a function of time
i'll write r of t
so it's r of t which we're squaring we
want to find the derivative of this with
respect to time
and here we just have to apply the chain
rule we're taking the derivative
of something squared with respect to
that something so the derivative of that
something squared with respect to the
something is going to be
2 times
2 times that something to the first
power and then we're going to let me
make it clear this is the derivative of
this is the derivative of r of t
squared
with respect to r of t the derivative of
something squared with respect to that
something if it was the derivative of x
squared with respect to x we'd have 2x
if it's the derivative of r of t squared
with respect to r of t it's 2r of t
but this doesn't get us just the
derivative with respect to time this is
just the derivative with respect to r of
t with the derivative with respect to
the derivative which this changes with
respect to time we have to multiply this
times the rate at which
the rate at which r of t
the rate at which r of g changes with
respect to time
so the rate at which r of t changes with
respect to time well we could just write
that as d r
d t these are equivalent expressions and
of course we have our pi out front and i
just want to emphasize this is just the
chain rule right over here the
derivative of something squared with
respect to time is going to be the
derivative of the something squared with
respect to the something so that's 2
times the something times the derivative
of that something with respect to time i
can't emphasize enough what we did right
over here this is the chain rule that is
that is the chain rule so we're left
with pi times this is equal to the
derivative of our area with respect to
time
now what do let me rewrite all of this
again just so it cleans up a little bit
so we have the derivative of our area
with respect to time
is equal to pi
times actually put that 2 out front is
equal to 2
2 times pi
times i can now switch back to just
calling this r we know that r is a
function of t so i'll just write 2 pi
times r times dr dt which let me make
the r in blue
2 pi r
dr dt
dr dr
dt
now what do we know we know what r is we
know that r at this moment right right
in time is three centimeters
right now r is three centimeters we know
dr dt
right now is one centimeter per second
we know this is one centimeter
per second so what's da dt going to be
equal to what's going to be equal to
that same green
2 pi
times 3
times 1
times that's purple times 1 times 1
centimeter per second and let's make
sure we get the units right so we have a
centimeter times a centimeter so it's
going to be centimeters
that's too dark of a color it's going to
be square centimeters centimeters times
centimeters square centimeter per second
which is the exact units we need for a
change in area so we have d a dt is
equal to this d a
the rate at which area is changing with
respect to time is equal to
6 pi
so it's going to be a little bit over 18
centimeters squared
centimeters centimeters squared
per second right at that moment yep
three times two pi so six pi centimeters
square per second is how fast the area
is changing and we are done